creo que ya hemos tenido bastante
exposición de lo que es la fórmula
cuadrática pero en caso de que no lo han
memorizado aún déjenme escribirla aquí
abajo así que vamos a tener una ecuación
cuadrática de la forma x cuadrada más bx
más c igual a 0 muy bien la fórmula
cuadrática que hemos demostrado en el
último vídeo dice que las soluciones a
esta ecuación son x igual a menos b más
menos la raíz cuadrada de cuadrada menos
4 hace sobre todo esto sobre 2a
ahora en este vídeo en vez de dar un
montón de ejemplos de cómo sustituir la
b y la c en esta fórmula quiero hablar
un poquito más de esta parte de la de la
fórmula cuadrática esta parte la be
cuadrada menos 4 a c ok y hemos visto en
varios problemas que hemos hecho de
algunos ejemplos que este tipo de este
este número determina cómo se ven las
soluciones es decir si por ejemplo b
menos 4 de cuadrada menos 4 ac es mayor
que 0 ok vamos a suponer ese caso
ahorita que vamos a tener pues vamos a
tener dos soluciones verdad la raíz
cuadrada de algún número positivo
siempre es este que sea distinto de cero
es el número por supuesto vamos a tener
dos verdad dos soluciones entonces esto
nos da implícitamente dos soluciones
menos b entre 2 a más o menos esta raíz
entre 2 así que el discriminante si es
mayor que 0 nos dice que
esta ecuación cuadrática ajá tiene dos
soluciones dos soluciones ok y esa es la
palabra para definir a este numerito de
cuadrada menos cuatro hace es
discriminante ok déjenme hacer lo mejor
con otro color
este número de aquí es el discriminante
de la ecuación cuadrática de estar acá
discriminante
y solo para recordarlo esta es la parte
que está dentro de la raíz del signo de
la raíz y es por eso que es tan
importante porque si es mayor que cero
tienes dos raíces verdad dos soluciones
a esta ecuación ahora qué pasa si b
cuadrada menos 4 ac es igual a cero
bueno si esto es igual a cero entonces
tenemos que esta parte dentro de la raíz
de cuadrada menos 4 c es igual a 0 ok
entonces la raíz cuadrada de 0 solo es 0
y de hecho entonces tienes que la única
raíz es menos b entre 2 a la verdad
y otra forma de pensarlo es que sólo
tienes una sola solución así que si el
discriminante es igual a cero tú vas a
tener una única solución una solución
sólo tienes una solución y de hecho va a
ser el vértice de la parábola verdad
cuando gráfica mos la la la equis
cuadrada más bx más c entonces las
soluciones el vértice de esta parábola
que le da como como un besito al eje x
que es donde se encuentran las
soluciones es donde se si la parábola se
intersecta con el eje x es donde están
las soluciones en este caso tenemos una
vámonos al caso en que ve cuadrada menos
4 hace es menor que cero entonces aquí
vamos a tener un número negativo dentro
de una raíz y vimos un ejemplo de eso en
el último vídeo verdad estábamos
trabajando con números reales y no
podemos tomar la raíz cuadrada de un
número negativo así que no tenemos
soluciones reales en el futuro veremos
como eso sí puede tener soluciones
complejas pero estamos trabajando con
números reales y por lo tanto no hay
solución ok la raíz cuadrada de un
número negativo no existe no tiene
sentido en los números reales
y ahora podemos pensar más acerca de
esto si tenemos que b cuadrada menos 4
hace digamos podemos pensar cuando las
soluciones van a ser números racionales
o no verdad por ejemplo si b cuadrada
menos 4 a 6 2 pues no vamos a tener
soluciones reales perdón racionales
porque la raíz cuadrada de 2 no es un
número racional verdad entonces vamos a
tener una solución irracional entonces
con todo esto dicho vamos a hacer
algunos ejemplos para ver cómo esto
cobra sentido y aterrizar ideas tomemos
este polinomio el menos x cuadrada más 3
x menos 6 igual a 0 y sólo voy a estar
concentrado en determinar qué tipo de
soluciones tiene esto no quiero resolver
la ecuación solo quiero saber cuántas
soluciones tiene y lo podemos determinar
a través del discriminante así que vamos
a ver analizar cuál es el discriminante
aquí b cuadrada es 9 menos
4 por qué es menos 1 por sé que es menos
6 muy bien entonces esto es igual a
cuánto esto se puede convertir como en
números positivos haciendo la operación
de los signos entonces tengo 9 menos 6
por 4 24 verdad que es mucho menor que
cero así que vamos a tener un número
menor que cero dentro del radical por lo
tanto no tenemos soluciones reales
porque ese es este escenario que tenemos
justo aquí así que la gráfica que de
hecho se va para abajo porque tenemos un
signo menos en el x cuadrada en el
término cuadrática si ese es el eje x
entonces la parábola se ve de esta forma
no el vértice está debajo del eje x y la
parábola abre hacia abajo entonces no
tenemos soluciones reales vamos a hacer
otro digamos que tengo déjenme hacer
esto en rosa digamos que tengo la
ecuación 5x cuadrada igual a 6x bueno
vamos a poner esto en la forma que hemos
usado siempre así que restamos 6x de
ambos lados y me quedan 5 x cuadrada
menos 6 x igual a 0
y vamos a calcular aquí el discriminante
así que queremos obtener be cuadrada
menos 4 hace verdad de cuadradas menos 6
al cuadrado menos 4
porsche y aquí no se ve la verdad pero
podemos pensar que estamos sumando un 0
entonces c es igual a 0
no hay c en la ecuación por lo tanto
podemos pensar que es 0 así que todo
esto se hace 0 y tenemos que menos 6 al
cuadrado es 36 así que el discriminante
es positivo tendríamos un 136 bajo de la
raíz y de hecho es un número cuadrado
perfecto verdad eso me dice que va a
tener dos soluciones racionales dos
soluciones reales y que además de eso
son racionales verdad porque el
discriminante resultó ser 36 que es 6 al
cuadrado es decir eso es un cuadrado
perfecto verdad entonces vamos a tener
soluciones reales pero además son
racionales
es este escenario de acá arriba y además
y además le sumamos el escenario de que
es un número racional verdad
vamos a hacer un par más ya que estamos
centrados en este tema entonces digamos
que tengo el 41 x cuadrada menos 31 x
menos 52 igual a cero otra vez quiero
pensar en cuánto cuántas soluciones
puede tener esta ecuación entonces de
cuadrada va a ser 40 perdón menos 31 al
cuadrado menos 4 que en este caso es 41
con otro a porsche que es menos 52 muy
bien entonces que tengo aquí esto el
primer de sumando en realidad es algo
positivo y el segundo también porque si
multiplicamos los signos me dan más
verdad así que tengo algo positivo el
primer término es 31 al cuadrado más
está en esta multiplicación que no la
voy a calcular pero es 4 por 41 por 52 y
solo me importa el signo del
discriminante en este caso es mayor que
0 eso significa que tengo dos soluciones
reales
y podríamos pensar si esto es por
ejemplo racional o irracional pero
requiere de muchos cálculos y no lo voy
a hacer ahorita ok entonces sabemos que
son reales no sabemos si son racionales
o irracionales pero bueno al menos hay
dos más bien exactamente hay dos digamos
que tengo ahora
x cuadrada x cuadrada menos 8 x + 16
igual a cero otra vez vamos a mirar
quién es el discriminante de cuadrada es
menos 8 al cuadrado menos 4 que es 1
porsche que es 16
ok esto es igual a 64 menos 4 por 16 que
64 y eso nos da 0 entonces sólo tengo
una solución
sólo tengo una solución y va a ser de
hecho
racional verdad va a ser racional de
hecho esto es x 4 x x 4 ese es el mismo
polinomio solo que factor izado y por lo
tanto x va a ser igual a 4 cuando digo
por definición de la fórmula cuadrática
puedes mirar que aquí si esto es 0
entonces las soluciones menos b entre 2
haber dado y si esos 2 serán números
enteros tenemos una solución racional
espero que de esta forma rápida tengas
claro cómo saber cuántas soluciones
tengo en una ecuación cuadrática si son
reales o si son o si no existen si
pueden ser racionales el discriminante
puede ser un atajo para resolver este
tipo de problemas verdad y te permite
apreciar la la belleza de esta fórmula